hey guys now this is going to be a very
quick and informative video
you know those times when you walk
somewhere and suddenly your shoelaces
come undone
it's annoying isn't it well in this
video i'm going to show you the best
knot the best way to tie your shoes so
that they will never come undone now
normally people just make a double knot
right but that's not good because it
looks bad and it is more difficult to
loosen it again later not only that but
the single knot or the double knot it
gets kind of skewed it doesn't look that
good and if you have the double knot
it's a little bit more difficult to
loosen it later so what you want to do
is this tie the first part normally as
you usually do but now instead of
crossing over to the right side you go
the other way underneath around like
this
now it lies perfectly across your shoe
and it won't come undone easily
now if you have any other style fitness
grooming or life video requests just add
them in the comments section down below
and i'll see if i can make a video about
it and always remember this guys before
you go
life is short
so don't waste yours cheers guys